sollten regierungskritiker in der korona
krise keine große bühne bekommen zdf
moderator jan böhmermann hat mit seiner
forderung nach einem auftrittsverbot für
kritische virologen eine debatte
losgetreten
doch er ist nicht der erste seit beginn
der korona krise versuchen journalisten
politiker und auch wissenschaftler diese
forscher aus der debatte auszuschließen
gleich bei uns hier im studio die
analyse mit bild meinungs- chef philippe
piatti der jetzt bei uns ist wir freuen
uns sehr hallo philipp patricia ich hab
das jetzt einmal kurz abgerissen was
dort passiert dass wir schauen uns das
auch gleich genauer an gib uns einmal
den überblick darüber das sagt sich so
leicht es soll niemand ausgegrenzt
werden aus der debatte grund dafür ist
eine podiumsdiskussion mit jan bermann
ganz genau ich habe man hat das in den
raum gestellt wieder ganz ganz aktiv und
hat das zum debatten thema nummer eins
gemacht und es geht hier um ein wort
dass viele vielleicht schon mal gehört
haben wir finden das ist das
gefährlichste worte corona krise die so
genannte falls balance die falsche
gewichtung das falsche gleichgewicht und
das soll heißen dass angeblich
minderheitsmeinung also meinungen von
außenseitern zu prominent vertreten
waren in den medien und deshalb zum
beispiel deutschland zu spät in der lok
tor gegangen ist zu spät maßnahmen
verhängt hat weil angeblich eben auf
hendrik strikt auf jonas
schmidt-chanasit und andere kritische
dass auch die außenseiter die du mit
außenseiter mainz völlig richtig das
sind stimmen die von der bundesregierung
vom kanzleramt ganz bewusst nicht gehört
wurden nicht gehört also man wollte sie
auch nicht hören man hat sie nicht zu
dem mp cars eingeladen man hat
stattdessen auf karl lauterbach auf
christian drosten und andere was
sicherlich sehr kompetente experten
gesetzt nur das was mir persönlich sorge
macht also ehrlich gesagt jeder virologe
der wirklich attackiert wird verbal auf
demonstration von querdenkern das ist
widerlich was mir aber fast noch mehr
sorge macht ist wenn von rund von
renommierten medien von politikern und
auch von renommierten wissenschaftlern
andere forscher andere experten
hingestellt werden als gefährlicher
außenseiter den man eigentlich nicht
trauen sollten ist es ja grundsätzlich
sowieso so gewesen wenn man es mal so
ein bisschen regen
wir lassen in dieser ganzen zeit
am ende war's fragt vier virologen und
du bekommst fünf meinungen und man war
eigentlich je mehr man gehört hat je
weniger schlau war man eigentlich am
ende ich habe mich am anfang mit drosten
immer sehr gut gefühlt so gut informiert
gefühlt muss ich sagen das war ja auch
eine phase wo es einfach nur um
vertrauen gegen es hat keiner hat wusste
wirklich es gab keine erfahrungswerte
man musste sich auf jemanden verlassen
und leute wie drosten und auch
lauterbach der sich daher durchaus
profiliert hat in dieser phase waren
leute an die man glauben konnte auf die
man sich verlassen konnte völlig richtig
das war die erste phase der pandemie die
erste welle der erste lockdown ehrlich
gesagt gab es diese großen
streitigkeiten damals noch überhaupt
nicht dass begann erst danach als ich
das alles etwas gelegt hat und als klar
wurde hendrik strikt will er lockern
christian drosten setzt auf den
vorsichtigeren kurs karl lauterbach
sowieso und als wir dann in den herbst
kamen in den ersten krone herbst dann
brachen wirklich diese streitigkeiten
auf und da wurde zum teil wie ich finde
mit etwas schmutzigen mitteln gearbeitet
und da wurde versucht eben experten an
den rand zu drängen und ihre meinung als
nicht legitim als sogar gefährlich
darzustellen diese debatte die kocht
jetzt wieder hoch fans gesagt philipp
grund dafür ist eine podiumsdiskussion
mit jan böhmermann in die wichtigsten
aussagen wollen wir jetzt auch ein mal
hereinschauen
diplomatisch zu finden falls balance ja
ja ja ja die berühmte falls bist du
sagst dir unserem tor soll her dass
irgendwas passiert sein müsse man lerne
ich finde es schwierig
wenn man leuten eine bühne gibt die eine
meinung vertreten die man nur deswegen
veröffentlicht weil man sagt man muss
auch die andere seite ihr sehen und es
gibt meinungen die sind so durchtränkt
von menschenfeindlichkeit oder so
motiviert von
von dingen die nichts damit zu tun haben
und zwar ersichtlich dass ich manchmal
fragen warum einige leute bei dir sitzen
ja warum einige leute bei dir sitzen und
der vorwurf der menschenfeindlichkeit
der weg schon philipp hat hier bei uns
im studio relativ schwer
menschenfeindlichkeit ich finde
einzuordnen dass man gäste und virologen
und meinungen genau abwägen soll den
vorwurf hat der markus lanz gemacht in
eine sendung einzuladen ich glaube dass
man das so würde auch markus lanz
zustimmen ordentlich abwägen soll
schauen soll ob das sendungskonzept ob
das passt aber eben gleichzeitig auch
die gefahr momentan nicht dass wir eine
falsche balance erzeugen dieses fonds
balancing wir laden nur jemanden ein der
mit krach dass der konkrete vorwurf von
jan böhmermann genau falls balance heißt
ja es gibt eigentlich einen
wissenschaftlichen konsens diese meinung
ist die richtige und trotzdem werden
außenseiter eingeladen und dann glauben
die zuschauer fälschlicherweise dass es
tatsächlich eine gleichwertige debatte
gibt obwohl es eigentlich alles völlig
klar ist so funktioniert wissenschaft
nicht so funktioniert aber auch politik
und demokratie nicht wenn wir uns europa
anschauen da hat jedes land einen
unterschiedlichen corona kurs gehabt
dass eine restriktive wie deutschland
beispielsweise dass andere etwas freier
wie schweden oder dänemark da kann man
nicht sagen es gibt diese eine meinung
und menschen als außenseiter an
angeblichen außenseitern sofort
menschenfeindlichkeit vorzuwerfen weil
sie einen etwas anderen corona kurs
wollen das halte ich schon wirklich für
sehr gewagt gleichzeitig wir sind ja
profis es gibt einen medienbetrieb jede
sendung hunderte talkshows jeder sucht
nach einem talk gast einen virologen und
so kam natürlich auch plötzlich
virologen in prominente position
die man sonst vielleicht gar nicht
angefragt hätte
gleichzeitig virologen die vielleicht
auch im umgang mit der öffentlichkeit
nicht so gestellt waren wie andere
profis und natürlich sind auch da bilder
erzeugt worden von den super profis und
von den weniger professionellen ja wir
sprechen ja konkret über zwei virologe
alexander kekulé und hendrik strikt auf
der einen seite die angeblich
außenseiter sind und dann die profis wie
christian drosten von der charité dazu
muss man aber einmal sagen hendrik
strick ist ja der nachfolger von
christian drosten in der virologie in
bonn auch er hat wirklich renommierte
studien veröffentlicht die weltweit
diskutiert wurden zum thema corona und
da kann man glaube ich nicht sagen das
ist halt irgendein außenseiter der nur
eingeladen um krawall zu stiften ich
glaube wenn man hendrik strikt kennt und
übrigens auch christian drosten das sind
keine krawalligen personen gegeben beide
relativ kompetent ihre interviews
versuchen sachlich zu bleiben klar bei
jedem scheint die polemik etwas durch
aber davor den genannten natürlich auch
in einem wettbewerb es war ja auch ein
wettbewerb der virologen sozusagen es
war eine große chance für sie sich zu
prüfen hat man vorher mal über virologen
geredet klar auch dass auch biologen
auch wissenschaftler sind natürlich
eitel und wenn man plötzlich in den
medien ist wenn man plötzlich zu
geheimen regierungskunden eingeladen
wird natürlich stellt sich da jeder
virologe und jeder andere experten hall
warum laden die immer nur den rosten ein
warum nicht nötig den strick also
insofern
ganz normal das konkurrenzverhalten ja
man muss natürlich auch sagen auch
strikt hat die bundesregierung beraten
er war auch im beraterkreis von jens
spahn er ist im expertengremium von
armin laschet in nrw also er ist nicht
irgendjemand den lanz eingeladen hat nur
damit man ein bisschen zur sache geht am
besten ist die pandemie ist am bald
vorbei und wir müssen überhaupt nicht
mehr über virologen sprechen hoffentlich
[Musik]